welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar nano structured
molecular li imprinted polymers robust
stable and selective alternatives to
antibodies it is presented by Adrienne
Kincaid PhD the CEO of MIP Diagnostics
my name is Judy O'Rourke and I will be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots
leopards is a leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before I begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits have located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Kincaid I will
now turn the presentation over to him
thank you very much for that
introduction and also the invitation to
give this presentation so not many
people have heard of America Lee
imprinted polymers which is a bit of a
mouthful so tend to call them myths and
certainly not the all modern myths which
I'll be speaking about today which are
now structured
maliki polymers or nano nips
so just to cover some of the different
versions of MIPS which exist the
original format was what we now call
bolt MIPS these were originally invented
in around
I think there's 1930 so they've been
around for a very long time and they're
formed by self-assembly of monomers
which form around a mixture of the
target or template molecule under them
colonized Institute to form a bulk
polymer with the target molecules
embedded within in that kind of
honeycomb instrument however they're
very difficult to use for all but a few
operations and what would be much more
like all would be something where you
could use it much more like an antibody
in other words of polymer antibody and
this is where nano mix I'm in space so
nano mix on screeched nano particles
combine containing just one binding site
per particle they can be manufactured in
different sizes but the typical range
for us since between 30 and 150
nanometers in diameter so slightly
larger than your traditional protein
antibody we can actually make them much
smaller than that and we can make them
so small that they become linear in
structure and are more like a chemical
Ultima so these can be sort of one two
three killer Dalton's in length and they
starting then to become more drug like
than actually polymer lung the other
form that's on this slide is what we
call our D YZ or rationally designed
polymers these can actually be made
using the monomers without the template
molecule so technically they're not
imprinted molecules
there are proprietary technologies on a
novel method to make nano nips which
circumvents a lot of the drawbacks
associated with the traditional and lip
manufacturing methods and the resultant
nano nips are very much like elastic
antibodies but are very easy to produce
and are incredibly robust comparison so
some main benefits of using nips
is compared to antibodies but it can
start with antibodies they have evolved
to being stable in physiological
conditions pH that when fall their about
body temperatures whatever they may be
but they are relatively expensive to
produce and being proteins and therefore
built up from 20 amino acids there is
some limitations to the chemistry that's
available to build a nancy boy
of course the speckled also determines
the surface area of the interacting
variable regions in proteins they can be
difficult to integrate into senses and
certain assays and certainly couldn't be
used for example in organic phase myths
on the other hand are very stable in
harsh conditions you can use them in
organic solvents and wash them with one
molar hydrochloric acid pH one and
they'll still survive basically you made
to you to work in seawater for example
or engineering assignment they're
incredibly robust they can be made to
bind it's 80 degrees centigrade and
indeed they can be autoclaved at 121
degrees centigrade and still retain
nanomolar affinity for their target
Aspen process they can be prepared for
any targets there's no immune response
required we don't use our Muse at all
but they can be used for any target from
very small molecules drugs or smaller
than that metabolites team right the way
up to through whole peptides whole
proteins and even viruses
they are incredibly easy to function
eyes because we can build in functional
groups for you you have control over the
chemistry of their composition
there are around 5,000 monomers
available for us to select from
they've all been used in the literature
and so much more chemically diverse than
20 amino acids of openness proteins
they're very fast in terms of
development all development project for
us is about six weeks and in terms of
manufacturing well that process in
itself takes about four hours so what
kinds of myths have we produced against
pretty much every target whether they're
farmers useful drugs or drugs of abuse
analytes toxins which may be a threat to
food security routines for studying drug
targets or other things biomarkers and
diagnostics we can produce them as I
mentioned earlier against whole cells or
viruses bacteria hives as a surrogate
for viruses as well Magnemite toxins
such as pesticides lindy's explosives
for high security applications so we are
not limited to those targets which would
elicit an immune response and small
molecule drugs are used commonly because
they don't listen immune response and
also hosts proteins should also not
elicit an immune response in that host
therefore very similar proteins are also
difficult to get into Princeton
none of these richness for us some of
the myths that we've developed in their
applications we've got customers and run
projects in a wide range of application
areas including drug discovery but also
Diagnostics decorations such as bio
processing and also our analysis we've
done this for a number of different
companies across a range of industries
if I take you through the manufacturing
process to make nano nips you're going
to better understanding as how they made
why they can be made the games so let me
take you through our proprietary
methodology well first of all we need to
understand what the project needs are or
what a customer needs are we then design
the monomer library that we're going to
use for that target selecting monomers
with a propensity to bind the target
this gives us the options target they've
given binding sites as well
so if you had for example a cofactor
drug bindings view a protein and enzyme
we can mimic that with a monomer and
bind to the same site if you had a drug
that bound to a known site we could
target that by using similar chemistry
to make monomers that are similar to
those and build MIPS around backsight
computational chemistry can be used and
indeed the old patent on the selection
of monomers or in silico or further
development in smooth nips once we get
into the manufacturing method we use our
proprietary solid-phase synthesis which
I like strain I'll explain in a bit more
detail later but in importantly we also
use controlled polymerization and again
I'll take more through this something
through this in more detail we command
functional groups either to the monomer
Nick's in terms of the bulk of the
polymer acids main or indeed we coat or
and cultural functionality to the outer
surface once made we then need to make
sure that it works in the way that we
want to certainly typically that
involves affinity for the target us
fearfulness me against or mac
opportunity core a selectivity target
only then will we ship nano mix to to
the customer or partner I have to use
synonyms and they saying seem like quite
a lot but the whole development process
takes about six weeks or so and in
comparison
making antibodies well they can take up
to nine or even ten months to
manufacture depending on the type of
antibody so let's take a closer look at
the monomers these are our building
blocks and the equivalent of mino acids
which make up proteins such as
antibodies so as I mentioned earlier
there's 5,000 different monomers
available in literature already have
already been used for making lips
various forms there are equivalents to
each of the functional groups of side
chains of amino acids within the
repertoire of monomers that we can use
and there's a host of other chemistry's
as well that you will not find in in
proteins this gives us a lot more
diversity enables us to make sure that
we get the best tool for the job in
making inanimate so the manufacturing
process itself starts with a target
molecule here we've got the rim
structure of melamine
so the nitrogen-rich six membered ring
that's attached to a long linkage jane
and via that attachment we immobilize it
and for solid support so in this case
we're using glass beams I should say
nothing on this slide is scale that the
idea is to get the message across this
to help me
we can then introduce the selection of
monomers as shown at the top of the box
here and each monomer is able to bind to
the target free in solution this means
that each interaction by a self-assembly
process it's actually optimized because
the monomer will find its lowest energy
state it's optimal binding position and
it's only when they're actually bound
into those positions that we will then
polymerize them in search you around the
target molecule this is done by using
controlled polymerization and we use UV
light to activate atlest
that's this produces free radicals
and creates the polymerization process
so that's represented here by the blue
blobs which are polymer and bound to the
active site again nothing on this is to
scale it's just to get the idea across
and we'll be back round for the
memorization low affinity polymers
formed and we want to remove those from
the mix well because we've immobilized
the target onto a solid support
effectively made an affinity column so
all we need to do is wash away the lower
cynics and components once we do that
the higher affinity components are
retained on the corn and we can increase
the stringency of the wash with the
aleutian process in order to harvest
those high affinity lips what you'll
also notice is that in this process
we've regenerated the corn and it's
possible to reuse a template molecule or
we use a column to make an additional
batch of nips it depends on how robust
the template molecule itself is if you
have a fragile protein it would be less
easy to reuse it but melamine us in this
example he actually makes 30 batches of
nano mix from the same column the
controlled polymerization is a key to
making this we want to get the
polymerization to bind each of the
monomers which are interacting the
template molecule in first single
instance so that they work together and
create a single binding site but what we
don't want to do is have each of these
individual nano nips or nano structured
directly imprinted polymers fusing
together or getting too large and we
want to be able to separate out each of
those binding sites
so having discrete particles is
essential we do this be using our
particular living reticle polymerization
method which relies as I said earlier on
UV light
when the UV light hits the list
it creates the free radicals with
promotes the polymerization however when
we turn the light off the same catalyst
now acts more like a bit than be mopped
up the free radicals inhibiting the
reaction and stopping the
criminalization process this slide just
shows you a cartoon trying that night
message across it's not a genuine crepes
this gives us the ability to mix in
slides this mix in fluorophores for
example into the monomer mix but it also
gives us the opportunity to the
polymerization change the monomers and
add a coat for example of smaller force
thank you myth fluorescent is relatively
straight food indeed we can build MIPS
around other particles preformed in the
mix so in the case of B panel here it's
say an iron oxide nano particle which is
in itself encapsulated in a slightly
lighter gray of the polymer nip that
we've formed this means that the myths
themselves are now inherently magnetic
by including monomers with various
functional groups enables us to attach
other entities to the Nano to the memory
itself so it's quite possible for us to
add a chlorophyll a drug a preteen
reporter free peptide iton free thigh or
groups for immobilization or indeed so
we have complete control over the
chemistry complete control over the
nature of the melanin is produced we can
make them hydrophobic or hydrophilic
positively charged or negatively charged
pretty much whatever size you need and
in the different colors it's making
whatever color you want
how consistently can we do that
we've been able to automate the process
of making banana myths we have a machine
which can think out the human error
involved in moving from back Spanish
effects are on this slide shows six
independent needs synthesized batches of
nan lips against the same target in this
case nsq bacteria fight which is a
surrogate for viruses but only can we
see that the diameter of banana nips
produced is consistent between 205 and
238 nanometers in diameter but also and
more importantly the Association
constant for the target is between 1.1
and 3.3 nano molar and six independent
determinations that's within an
experiment where it's all intents and
purposes and batteries are behaving
identically so how to lips compared to
the traditional antibodies which most
life sciences scientists have used well
it's rather controversial to generalize
and mount antibodies and similarly is
quite controversial to generalize nips
can gather the populations and typically
Nana myths are equivalent in terms of
their affinity to impose their high
affinity we also have the ability to
make lower affinity none of its if
that's required for a project you might
want something to bind and then be
released for separation for example or
sensors in real time robustness though
you find that no nips are very very
different proteins including antibodies
so they can withstand exposure up 221
degrees without a naturing because the
backbone is a carbon carbon carbon
carbon polyethylene chain it's not
biodegradable so then the shelf life
could be trimming
Seulong it's also very very chemically
stable as to manage variability as I
showed in the previous slide is
excellent and after then you don't
necessarily expect even from the mana
Queen certainly better from different
polyclonal productions from different
animals she'll fight we don't know but
it's probably in excess of 60 years also
time to develop in stove months we're
down to around six weeks the
manufacturing croats at time is about
four hours as opposed to making four
weeks for a batch of antibodies moving
on how do they compare in terms of a
things this is this slide shows two
blocks using difference fluorescence
attacks on on this and you can see they
work in much the same way as exploits
comparison Western blot where the myth
is on the left hand side and the
antibody is on the right hand side
targeting some degrading trypsin to show
the the different hopes and the
different bands that might be available
you can see virtually identical results
between the antibody and the myth
essentially more importantly the column
for the lies eight is showing virtually
no signal whatsoever
it's very very clean demonstrating that
the myth has very little nonspecific
binding medications of various Nana
myths include so this is relatively
novel development but we can use
inanimate made against a particular
binding site so we can select monomers
to target those particular sites do you
protect
aggradation of the target from Krypton
digest for enzyme been by using mass
spectrometry to determine the sequences
of what's being protected by the
we can determine where the myth is
binding this is a very rapid process and
allows us to get sequence data for
individual epitopes in around the Robin
it two weeks a project would take around
maybe even a year to do with antibodies
in hat raised for that process and so
this is also extremely useful for
hopping from one from a protein to a
height so that we can then mix two less
expensive peptide for use on proteins at
a later date it also enables us for
example to spot differences in epitopes
on various viruses so changing between
viral strains which can be very
important for vaccines research
detecting viruses and indeed removing
them in water has been something which
Nix has been useful so in this
particular case our best example where
the variations described earlier the
intention was to remove viruses from
drinking water to ensure it's safe
I've already talked about the
dissociation constants being ground moat
and nanomolar affinities but what was
also demonstrated was that we could
remove nine logs of clearance in terms
of removing viruses
yms to bacterial findings our surrogate
so that goes from one ileum back forming
units to one in a single column step mix
are very useful for you if you're using
in sensors we can take Nana MIPS and put
them into a film and attach that to a
sensor making an ideal for detection of
materials in real-time flow especially
when combined with the ability to adjust
the affinity for the targets there by
or predetermine infamously from the
Melanie manufacturing process we can use
them to image in imaging on a cellular
basis by not particular targets whether
they are membrane-bound proteins or
other elements of a cell all we can
indeed use them in wholesale a whole
animal imaging mightest their
internalization is something which has
been useful for drug delivery and
recovery approaches and in this
particular case we made nips to a non
clergy marker EGFR too and the one
supposed to the receptor was naturally
internalized by endocytosis by attaching
drugs to the outer surface in this case
like toxic drugs to the outer surface of
banana mix they can be released by after
internalization due to the change in the
chemistry of being internalized so
labile linker is used to deliver cargo
to the cell interestingly in this
particular case the Nano mix themselves
being non biodegradable find their way
to the lysosome and therefore it's
possible to determine the oaths on a
cell delivered to a cell when they sell
myself basis simply by counting up the
spots upon fate marks finitely small
arrows here within the lysosome of a
cell
comparing the phenotype to the number of
spots gives most response correlation so
in summary myth Diagnostics offer access
to nanotechnology which can be used in
broad range of projects including
applications and drug discovery it's
alternative 20 bodies in Diagnostics set
relations and by analysis proprietary
Manomet design and development processes
enable us to provide high quality nunim
it's typically within six weeks of
receiving the target and mainly
functionalized to suits the needs of
that particular project
excellent recognition properties been
achieved for small molecules at Heights
proteins and indeed whole viruses that
can also be modified with various
functionalities according to your needs
to make them fluorescent or less
chemically active all magnetic I should
like to thank you very much for your
attention during this talk and any
questions that you have I'll be happy to
answer via the email
thank you dr. Kincaid for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May 27th 2019
as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we'll see
you next time goodbye